[Music]
guess is an extreme angler biologist and
author he's also the host of animal
planet's most popular series of all time
River Monsters let's take a look I'm not
so strange feeling that's a very strange
feeling it's there's suction but there's
something sharp going on as well it's
really getting stuck in there
easier said than done ah ah come on that
is hard to get off that is hard that is
hard to get off
ah there's a mark there or not hopefully
there's not a big red hole
why please welcome Jeremy wait why did
you do that now you went into that River
in the in the hopes that that animal
would attach itself to you what I was
trying to do was recreate what happened
to a long-distance swimmer he was
swimming the length of Lake Champlain
and a load of these things attached to
him he didn't know what they were
including one on his neck like that so
it's just to get a sense of what that
must be like so what happened at that
guy that guy still has nightmares to
this day he's been in all sorts of
situations we said this thing really
traumatized him yeah I would just take
his word for it I wouldn't oh yeah that
sounds horrible I wouldn't be like wait
a minute
let's just see for ourselves he was
quite lucky though because what they can
do look at attached to your jugular
that's your jugular that's the main vein
supplying blood so dead it was it taking
blood from your body not at that point I
go it off in time and what they can do
and what they their modus operandi they
normally feed on fish and they normally
bore into the fish they've got this
sucker with teeth they got a tongue that
has teeth on it and it's treated a bit
like a piston they drill a hole and they
suck out the body fluids now they can be
suck out the body fluids from the fish
leaving just a husk of a fish exactly Oh
sometimes I mean at me I do go for
people but sometimes they're not wanting
to feed they're just they're just
hitching a ride they're on there they're
spawning run and it's just better than
swimming themselves they're just
attached and just hit your ride so you
can get out of the water and not we've
all had the experience of being in a
lake something you get out and there's
like maybe a leech or something but
coming out and having 12 of those things
hanging out of your body I would think
you would know it right you would know
until it hurts he said it felt like his
phone going off when the first one
attached but he then he realized he
wasn't wearing his phone because he is
in the yeah and your phone doesn't
usually suck your blood out
unless you have the new one that just
came out the new the new iPhone